[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut rêver à un monde meilleur et on
peut réfléchir ensemble comment y
arriver pour faire en sorte que
seulement on évite les scénarios
catastrophes est devenu un rituel quasi
quotidiens marché sur le mont royal
une nécessité pour ie choix bendjo la
marche c'est comme une sorte de
méditation dans laquelle les pensées
vont assez librement on n'est pas
encombré par ce qui se passe dans
l'immédiat et ses serments créatif donc
c'est important de préserver ce moment
là chaque journée car il n'ya pas assez
de rang une journée pour yoshua bengio
un des scientifiques québécois les plus
en demande dans le monde
l'intelligence artificielle intrigue
dérange deux visions s'affrontent à 53
ans ce chercheur demeure une référence
internationale car il a contribué à
développer une expertise en
apprentissage automatique
à l'intérieur de cette discipline de
l'apprentissage automatique et fait
partie bien tes chances officiel une
sous discipline qui s'appelle
l'apprentissage profond qui est inspiré
de connaissance pendant du cerveau et
pour lesquelles on est vraiment des
pionniers on est parmi les meilleurs au
monde et on a le plus gros centre de
recherche universitaire sur ce sujet
nord au monde et c'est ce qui fait venir
les compagnies du monde entier grâce à
lui montréal peut prétendre d'être la
capitale de l'intelligence artificielle
et l'étude de systèmes intelligents l'on
peut prendre des décisions dans
différents domaines et on espère les
amener à un niveau d'intelligence qu'il
comparable à celle de l'humain
l'intelligence artificielle risque de
complètement révolutionné notre mode de
vie actuel
selon lui cette révolution va être
beaucoup plus rapide plus fulgurante que
la révolution industrielle en santé des
robots pourront faire l'analyse des
radiologies le domaine des arts se
transforme également
cette musique que vous entendez depuis
le début du reportage a été composé
grâce à un programme de l'intelligence
artificielle
quant aux guerres elles pourront se
faire sans soldats avec des robots
tueurs
un scénario qui préoccupe yoshua bengio
larmes décide tout seul de tuer
quelqu'un sent qu'il ya un humain qui
pressent la gâchette qui autorise en
tous les cas l'intelligence artificielle
s'imposera de plus en plus dans notre
vie quotidienne
beaucoup craignent que cette
intelligence basée sur des algorithmes
détruisent des emplois et que des êtres
humains se retrouve totalement démunis
face à cette révolution
cette caricature du new yorker reflète
bien cette crainte les médias qui vont
disparaître et il faut que les gens
sachent
mais on sait pas toujours davance
lesquels monde y en a évidemment tout ce
qui concerne les transports conducteur
les gens qui travaillent dans les
centres d'appels il ya des chances ou
six
réaliste certes mais ce promeneur
solitaire croit en cette révolution
qu'ils voient d'un oeil plutôt optimiste
je crois qu'il va avoir une valorisation
des emplois qui implique l'humain donc
tu ce cap-là humain à humain
parce que on voudra pas que les machines
face certains s'occupent de certains
plans veut pas que un robot s'occupe de
nos enfants ce que nos aînés s'occupe de
nos malades
moi j'ai pas envie que mon psychologue
soit un robot il imagine un monde
meilleur que celui d'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'aujourd'hui pour beaucoup de
gens le travail c'est ça reste une sorte
d' esclavage
on travaille parce qu'il nous faut un
salaire pour vivre payer notre maison
etc
je je je visualise une société future ou
le travail c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait pour contribuer à la société pour
s'épanouir pour avoir l'impression de
nodier est un sens et appartements ou
les questions matérielles vont être
amoindrie peut-être par exemple par un
revenu garanti ou d'autres mécanismes et
aussi parce que beaucoup de choses vont
coûter moins cher parce que c'est les
ordinateurs qui vont le faire mais on
peut rêver ce genre de société c'est ici
qu'on travaille un monde presque idéale
ils y croient car lui même vit de sa
passion yoshua bengio aurait pu céder
aux chants des sirènes avoir un salaire
mirobolant et vivre aux états unis
il a choisi de rester à montréal
continuer à enseigner à l'institut des
algorithmes d'apprentissage le millas et
ce sont les compagnies qui viennent à
lui né à paris il est arrivé au québec à
l'âge de 10 ans très tôt il a développé
un intérêt pour les ordinateurs avec son
frère samuel quand on était adolescent
on a économisé un peu là on vendait des
journaux et et on a pris notre argent on
a acheté à apple 2 e puis un atari 800
et à cette époque là il n'y avait pas de
programme tout fait de jeu etc
il fallait programmer nous-mêmes c'était
vraiment l'âge de pierre de
l'informatique
donc là j'ai appris à programmer c'est
devenu un peu une passion une passion
qui se poursuit trente ans plus tard
avec toujours cette vision d'un monde
meilleur grâce à la science
[Musique]